Dallas Texas a monster beach ball is on
the loose
looks like Godzilla has lost his beach
ball this world record breaking ball is
a mass of 36 feet in diameter look out I
thought they were gonna be crushed
seriously how long did it take to blow
this thing up the way the bowl Falls is
weird because it looks like it's falling
in slow motion so why is it more of a
floating far than a wrecking ball the
ball falls of course because gravity is
pulling it down but there's another
force acting opposite to the direction
of motion and that's pushing up and
that's the drag force the amount of drag
is determined by the size and shape of
the object and in general the bigger the
object the more drag it has through the
air large objects tend to have a lot of
weight to them so they have enough force
to overcome the drag but the beach ball
is just filled with air so there's no
real mass to it so it doesn't have
enough force to overcome its own drag
and that's why it looks like it's
floating down onto the crowd